[Music]
i ran through the stretch
[Applause]
and i just for the second i thought i
might get away
thought then i know where all this
police come
jump somewhere was wrestling with me
that me
game over
they led me to a medical center
i knew i wasn't getting home
the doctor puts the x-ray on this white
light
it shows from my neck all through me
intestines i was loaded up from head to
toe
and he goes
even the police officers were shocked
and the doctor went to me but come on
you do know if one of these bursts
you're dead don't you
so they gave me a load of fluid laxative
fluid
then after after a while the computers
have needed to go to the toilet
i need to toilet not toilet and they
said right you've got to go in that
bucket
so what
five minutes later i'm squatting over
his bucket
feeling embarrassed
i'm squeezing my stomach
and it was like a machine gun
as all these pellets come shooting out
took three days to get all of them out
[Music]
it took me 12 hours to get him in
but three days to come out
and finally the doctor was telling the
police yeah he's he's
clear so i was expecting some sort of
trial
some sort of court hearing
but i wasn't no didn't happen though i
shackled by my feet
and they escorted me out directly to the
prison
the prison was in the middle of a shanty
time
i didn't know what to expect
i'm
waddling along because of the shackles
i'd have to walk in there
it hits me it's like wow it was like a
nightmare
i've been to prison many times before
but this one's a whole different
ballgame
[Music]
uk prisons are like holiday camps
compared to india
i was scared it was i was frightened
and then he said right get in there
and you're gonna sleep on that floor
there
there's people everywhere it was
overcrowded it was like it's inhumane
living conditions
and then
it's time for lights out
you see the light is
all over the place people are smoking
crack
and amongst the flickers on the walls
you can see these cockroaches
crawling all over the people's backs and
over the faces
at that moment everything closed in on
me
there's nowhere to go i couldn't escape
me demons i couldn't escape the
nightmare i was in i couldn't escape the
place where i was
i hated myself
because i was now locked up abroad
i was now one of them people
that had seen on the tv years and years
earlier
i was now living that nightmare
[Music]
you